one of the best responses we've had from
from young girls seeing this film and
Englanders you know them tweeting I'll
never not use my vote again and I think
that's that's so much a part of why we
wanted to make the story just to really
get people to understand that there was
a huge sacrifice that was made by these
women
hello Carey Mulligan welcome to the
frontrunners I'm really happy to see you
here today thanks for having me okay so
your role of Maud watts in suffragette
is such a powerful phenomenal part how
badly did you fight to get it I actually
was in the extraordinarily lucky
position of being offered it you know it
was such an amazing role and and more so
than that even was just the story that
we were telling um that for some reason
had never been told before and that was
extraordinary the women that are
portrayed in this movie they're truly
empowering to a lot of people who watch
the film who in your life would you say
has been the most empowering influence
on you I think probably my mother has
been most empowering you know she's
always stood behind my choices and it
not necessarily thinking that they were
the best idea physically becoming an
actor that was not something that she
was wildly excited about and she was
nervous about it but she stood behind
and and she's also always encouraged me
to stand behind the things that I
believe in and be honest and strong
about them even if they're not popular
things to believe in or say and I think
that's something that these women also
did this they stood up for things even
though they were wildly unpopular and
that's something my mother's always
instilled in me and so I'm grateful to
ever done and how did these women
compared to you do you feel like could
you have the wherewithal and the guts to
do some of the stuff that they do in the
movies no heart you know it really I
think what's amazing is that so many
women did and they lost so much I mean
and especially working classes they were
losing you know their jobs and their
husbands and their children and and I
think it just goes to show we know the
level of desperation that they'd reach
that they were able to do that because
they do do really extreme things and
they did them and they're in the film
but I think you have to get to a certain
breaking point to be capable of that
sister well we're gonna watch a very
heart-wrenching scene from suffragette
this is a moment where you return home
to find out some shocking news about
developments in your family so let's
take a look and we'll talk about it yeah
say your good-byes and then let him go
Jody
come on a step is Maud watts don't
forget what was it like for you to look
into his eyes during yeah it was hard
what going into it we knew that he would
find it emotional because in the
read-through he had to leave the room
because he found it so upsetting you
know and he was young you know and it's
hard for children to kind of different
you know and be had a wonderful parents
and very supportive so he was very well
at bafta but it was we knew it was going
to be roughing so we actually shot
everything of him first but take some we
were on him I think we only did two
takes on him in both times you just lost
it Wow and then they yeah turn around
can you even imagine having anything in
your life that would jeopardize the
relationship with your young child like
like this character did no I know it's
it just shows what it was like for these
women that they that you know this this
wasn't something they chose this was
something that was taken from them but
that they endured it and they had the
strength to do I think just is a marker
of how bad things were for women at that
time and how much they felt that they
needed to do what they were doing here's
the end of this heart-wrenching moment
here cuz I'll be why you decided what
are you flying me George
what is it laughs as I know it says I
know I know what is it like to watch
this now that you have such a beautiful
young baby daughter yeah it's different
I suppose every time you watch a
performance you have a sort of year or
two years experience and and you wish
you could invest it into the you know is
that that's the problem with cinema is
that everything's capturing the moment
so I suppose everything builds anything
oh well now I know this i would do this
and you know but yeah I mean you'd spend
your whole career doing that do you look
forward to a day when you can show her
this film yeah I do I do um but actually
what happened is such a huge moment in
our history if I'd had a son I would
have wanted him to see us as well for
the same reasons you know and I think
that's what's so great that moored has a
son in the film because she's doing this
for him as much as she would do if her
daughter do you feel proud of the fact
that this is a movie directed by a woman
written by a woman with a largely female
cast about this phenomenal group of
women is that something that's important
to you yeah is I mean you know it's just
a whole new experience written directed
and produced and so many of the
creatives were women as well and I think
it took a group of women to get it made
at if you would have been made by group
of men and I do think that if the story
had been a man story it would have been
told a thousand times by now and because
it's about women it hasn't been and so
to get to be a part of that group is is
so extraordinary well thank you so much
for taking the time to talk to us about
this and we survived it we got through
the scene well done thank you be sure to
see the entire film of suffragettes buy
your tickets on fandango and thank you
so much to the TCL chinese theatre imax
for having us here today and thank you
for watching fandango frontrunners
you